[Music]
they stole his car they killed his dog
now he was gonna kill 76 people who
worked for the dad of the kid who did it
John wig strapped in with a sleeper hit
of 2014 that your friends would not shut
up about combining that no-nonsense
revenge movies of the past with a slick
production techniques of today in an
action flick that doesn't rely on quick
cuts or shaky cam I didn't even know you
were allowed to do that
how does Liam Neeson gonna hop a fence
in the next take in man that must have
taken them a while I mean seriously that
was like 14 different camera angles me
John wick the man whose mere name makes
criminals reconsider their life choices
he stole John with his car oh oh
witness kion owes eight and arguably
best character named John he's a retired
hitman tragically in love with a video
clip but after the world was depressing
crime he'll turn the entire world into a
game of Call of Duty on the easiest
difficulty
to both the man himself enter a
mysterious shadow society of assassins
where everyone is way too casual about
dead bodies you are working again
complete with its own mysterious
currency cleanup crew hotel bar health
care car service and assassin jazz band
yes so is there like an assassin Yelp
assassin day care assassin jelly we
really have to clear all that up in John
way to watch as John hunts down Theon
Greyjoy who's gone from literally
[ __ ] to metaphorically [ __ ] one
another bottle in breathtaking action
sequences where John kills countless
actual Red Shirts culminating in a
finale where he casually shoots the
person who's been hunting Ben wrestles
an old and out of chic Russian dad in
the rain
[Music]
huh kind of feels like they blew their
budget that nightclub scene so pull up a
front row seat to the key on Assad's as
this immortal 50 year old still kicks
just as much ass as he did in his 20s
and finally loses the trademark chill
he's been building up since Bill and Ted
as we pray that Keanu pulls off what
he's never done before follow up a great
action movie with a sequel that doesn't
suck you have many questions and though
the process has altered your
consciousness you remain irrevocably
human concordantly while your first
question may be the most pertinent you
may or may not realize it is also the
most irrelevant your life is the sum of
a remainder of an unbalanced equation
inherent to the programming of the
mastering I know gun foo to friend or to
foe head shots Russian reek Friday Night
Lights out for head shots
Winston Churchill super shredder in
Ninja Turtles - and Wow this movie is
like 80% headshots a dog's purpose man
Jon so good at shooting he doesn't even
shoot vertical video hey screen junkies
want to hear how Keanu Reeves really
feels about John wick I just want to
kill this one kid I'm not crazy
then check out our second edition of
honest interviews where we asked Keanu
and the people behind John wick to to
answer our dumb questions click the box
in the left to watch our interview or
click the Box on the right to check out
our screen junkies Roast of Batman whoa
always bet on black he said welcome to
the frickin guardians of the galaxy only
he didn't say friggin brother I require
your oats
all hail princes trunks